my amazing mom she's my hero you know my
mom was selling stuff in the street I
have money to buy a plate of food and
she always saw the future in us she
always believed in that she was always
there for us she's the foundation of
this family
back in the day we had to work until we
saw something you got to do it every day
you got to work more
than anybody else just believe on what
you're doing keep working you know don't
let nobody tell you what you can build
what you cannot do every year you work
you work towards something two years ago
right which is to get a promotion to be
able to uh take care of your family
provide the house for them or take care
of your parents you work two years ago
it's not a failure it's steps to success
there's always steps to it you know
Michael Jordan played 15 years won six
Championship the other nine years was a
failure there's no failure in sports
you know there's good days bad days some
days some days you are able to uh be
successful so that you're not some days
it's your turn so this is not your turn
and that's what sport is about you don't
always win some other other people's
gonna win and this year somebody else
want to win similar that we're going to
come back next year try to be better try
to build good habits
uh it was kind of hard you know I was I
grew up with my family I never left the
country before that right to me get
getting drafted and uh just not having
my family around it was uh the first
moment stuff my dad's not sure with me
but uh you know two two years ago and um
you know I had to go in my head that I'm
going I'm gonna be the best player in
the league yeah I'm gonna do whatever it
takes to help my team win and I'm going
to MVP
and uh everything every day that I step
on the floor I always think about my dad
and that motivates me and they pushed me
to you know play hard in it
move forward even though when my body's
sore even though when I I don't feel
like playing I was gonna show up and I
was gonna do the right thing you have a
good parent
your parents is the future for you and
she always saw the future in US you
always believe in us she was always
there for us you're my you're my true
hero you're my true hero when you focus
on the past that's your ego I did this
you know
um
we're able to beat this team for all we
did I did this in the past I want that
in the past and when I folks in the
future is my pride like yeah next game
game five I do this and this and this
right you know I'm going down that's
your pride attack like you it doesn't
happen like you're right here and
um I kind of like try to focus in the
you know in the moment in the present
and that's humility that's being humble
that's not setting no expectation that's
going out there enjoying the game
competing in a high level and I think
I've had people throughout my life that
helped me with that but that's a skill
that I've tried to like Master it and uh
it's been working so far yeah so I'm not
gonna stop
gotta take everybody uh you got to be
consistent you got one more than
anybody
anybody else out there because of my
personality being low profile and
do not want to put myself out there
as much as other players want to put
theirselves out there and
um what I said is that if I cannot be
the face of the league being myself and
do what I do
I'm good without
I'm good you always think about you know
my childhood uh myself
just being you know raised and born in
Greece but definitely when I see that
the energy of like I know that my
parents are extremely proud and you know
my dad watch from above I know he'll be
with a smile in his face definitely not
gonna change my personality change you
know who I am
I'm not gonna chase for nobody and
not from the NBA not not for the media
enough for anything I know where I came
from I know where I started from
um I know what me and my family have
been through
something that I take pride why are you
so careful with your money it was a lot
of people think that I'm cheap but I'm
not I spend a lot of money in my family
but
I'll spend money on myself
um but I'm just careful with my money
because I know they've got the value of
money you know
a lot of people out there think that you
know a lot of NBA players just spend
their money and blow through the money
do whatever they want but uh you know
the way I grew up and the way that it's
been fold every day and work every day
to have money uh even though now I've
signed had a million dollar deal I got
money from endorsements uh I I think I
never lost that bad
money and I hope I never lose it I hope
I give people around the world from
Africa from Europe give them hope you
know that it can be done
it can be done eight years ago eight and
a half years ago if I came to the league
I didn't know when my next move will
come from
you know my mom was still in stuck in
the street
like and now I'm here sitting in the top
of the top you know and and I'm
extremely blessed as my dad told me
you know always want more but never be
greedy my goal is to win a championship
and we're going to do whatever it takes
to make that happen I never thought you
know I'm gonna be 26 years old
you know with my team playing the NBA
Finals just playing and like I was just
happy just being a pie like you know not
even winning just being a part of this
of this journey you know and uh but I
never thought ever when I'd be 26 you
know I've been sitting this year with
this right here and this right here
man it's been it's been uh we've come a
long way
it's gonna happen for you you might not
make it in your career might be best it
might be anything just believe on what
you're doing keep working you know don't
let nobody tell you what you can be what
you cannot do you know people told me I
can't make free throws I made my free
throws tonight and I'm a freaking
champion